you as a consultant have an opportunity
that many other employees of the company
do not have and this is that you as part
of your project will very often be able
to talk to lots of different people at
the client from lots of different
departments and by that you will collect
lots of information the probably many
employees will not be able to have if
they just work on one specific task in
one specific department for their whole
career so often by talking to one client
you will pick up some industry Trends
some certain specific information on
what is going on in the company the
probably another client of yours another
employee of the company is not really
aware of you can then selectively share
some of the information that you got
from the first client and by that
because this other client might not be
aware of that he or she will then often
perceive you as a very competent very
well informed